[موسيقى]
في نتيجه انتخابات رئاسه تركيا لا جديد
لقد حافظت الموالاه والمعارضه على
اوزانهما في الصناديق ونال الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان نسبته المعتاده من الاصوات 52
بالمئه ونال معارضوه ايضا نسبهم المعتاده
التي وحدوها هذه المره بقدره قادر لصالح
مرشح واحد غير قادر كمال كليتش داروغلو
فجمعت له اصوات العلمانيين المتشددين
والمعتدلين والاسلاميين الزعلانين واتباع
فتح الله جولان المحظورين والقوميين
العنصريين والاكراد الانفصاليين
واليساريين واليمينيين والوسططيين
والمثليين ليسقط كليتش دارولو وينهي
مستقبله السياسي نهايه رقميه مشرفه ترى
اوس في المعارضه قبل الموالاه انه لا
يستحقها فهو الذي ضيع على المعارضه
باصراره على الترشح فرصه الاطاحه برجب طيب
اردوغان الذي سبق ان قال طالما ان خصمنا
هو السيد كليتش فهذا يعني اننا بخير الى
العناوين
اردوغان لولايه جديده برئاسه الجمهوريه
التركيه وليس بالخلافه الاسلاميه
قتال وقتلا بين افغانستان وايران فهل سقط
تفاهم طالبان سليمان
تصفيات مافياويه اسرائيليه في شوارع دبي
وسلطتها تعتقل الجناه
جثث عائمه على القبور في الجزائر بعد
فيضانات نادره بسبب الامطار
قرض ربوي لاتمام فريضه الحج اخر بدع
المصارف في مصر
شيرين عبد الوهاب لو كنت اعلم ان الحر
شديد
لاتيت اليكم بالمايوه
بيع الخمور الاجباري في زحله والتعري في
صيدا واجب وطني
بعد الحرير جنبلاط يعتزل العمل الحزبي
ووهب يقول ان اعتزال بري وزعزع وبسيل
مطلوب ايضا دوليا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا انها انتخابات رئاسه جمهوريه تركيا
العلمانيه التي تاسست نقدا للخلافه
العثمانيه وعلى انقاضها
فلماذا تعامل كثير من شعوب العالم
الاسلامي معها وتحديدا مع فوز اردوغان بها
بحماسه استثنائيه تفوقه اهتمام هذه الشعوب
بانتخاباتها المحليه فنسي العرب همومهم
وتسمروا امام الشاشات يترقبون فواصل
الارقام وادنى فيما وصلت التكبيرات بعد
اعلان النتيجه الى ماذن القرى النائيه في
البوسنه والهرسك
الاجوبه والتفسيرات كثيره في مقالات
الكتاب وتحليلات الخبراء فمن جهه كانت
انتخابات مواجهه معلنه من الغرب مع
اردوغان وكانت ايضا بحسب الكتاب دفاعا
روحيا عن حريه العباده الاسلاميه التي نكل
بها حزب الشعب الجمهوري منذ تاسيسه
والمتهم بافظع انواع الاستبداد الالحادي
من الاستهزاء بالمقدسات وتسخيفها الى منع
الاذان والحجاب الشرعي واطلاق اللحن
المشايخ وسجن العلماء وقتل المعترضين
وسجنهم وكانت ايضا معركه لحمايه اردوغان
ومن معه من مصير مجهول غير مضمون العداله
بين ايدي العلمانيه المتطرفه التي اعدمت
وتعظم خارج القانون وقد سبق ان هدد الرئيس
كتله حزب الشعب الج في البرلمان انجن
التاي حذر اردوغان بعد توعده بالهزيمه في
الانتخابات فقال امل ان لا ينتهي الامر
باردوغان مسلوقا مثل عدنان مندريس رئيس
الوزراء الحاج الذي اعدم شنقا عقبا انقلاب
عسكري عام
1960 وكانت حماسه الشعوب الاسلاميه ايضا
تعاطفا مع سته ملايين مهجر نصفهم سوريون
وصرح كليتش بانهم سيرحلون تالي يوم الفوز
وقال بعض المعلقين ايضا لولا الانتخابات
التركيه الديمقراطيه لا امكن لاسرائيل ان
تتصدق بتفردها بصنع انتخابات حقيقيه وحيده
في المنطقه
تعددت التفسيرات العقلانيه المتجرده لكن
تفسيرا عاطفيا نفسيا يرصد عطش الشعوب الى
قائد على مستوى العالم الاسلامي اسقطه
البعض على شخص اردوغان ولو بدلا عن ضائع
منذ مئه عام
الرحمن الرحيم ها هي الحلوى منتشره في خان
يونس على فوز اردوغان في الانتخابات بلغه
العقل والوعي للعاطفه والاندفاع الحقيقه
هي ان رجب طيب اردوغان اعاد حريه العبادات
الاسلاميه الى تركيا لكن بجمهوريه علمانيه
حليفه للناتو متفاهمه مع روسيا والصين
مطبعه مع اسرائيل وهي اخفقت مع الخليج ومع
كل العرب في التعامل مع نكبه الشعب السوري
اذا اردوغان ومن معه شكلوا ضمانات لحمايه
ماذن تركيا
ولمكافحه العنصريه والتمرد والشذوذ لكن
اردوغان الرئيس ليس خليفه المسلمين
ولن يكون وهو لا يريد ان يكون اصلا اتقن
اللعبه وامتلك الهيبه وصنع تنبيه غير
مسبوقه لبلاده فاجتمع خصومه
ليطل عليهم مساء الاحد من قصر انقره في
بدايه ولايه جديده من خمس سنوات وهكذا قال
اردوغان لكليتش باي باي كمال وسدد الصفعه
العثمانيه التي توعده بها
الذي تحول من علماني متطرف الى مفتي يحرم
انتخاب اردوغان في شرع الله وسنه رسوله
الكريم عشيه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
نهايه الامر اردوغان ولاكمال مسيره الحريه
والتنميه في تركيا عليه الانفتاح على
المعارضه وان كان ذلك سيجعله طاغيه في نظر
بعض الغرب الذي لا يحب في العالم الاسلامي
الا الطغاه الحقيقيين وتبقى الانتخابات
واجراءاتها امتحانا حقيقيا لتجسيد ممارسه
الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه والتداول السلمي على
السلطه قضيه الانتخابات التركيه بالكثير
من الاشادات الداخليه والخارجيه لجهه
نزاهتها لكن ماذا تفيدها هذه الاشادات ان
لم تحصل على مصادقه من رائد الديمقراطيه
في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وجنوبها
عبد الخالق عبد الله الذي لم يعجبه فارق
الاربع نقاط للرئيس الفائز فكيم جونغ اون
بجيب ميه بالميه بدون منافس
والكيمات جونغونات كتار بالمنطقه رجل
الاعمال الاماراتي خلف الحبتور كان اكثر
تواضعا وحكمه من مواطرها عبد الخالق فلم
يقيم التجارب الديمقراطيه تركها لاهلها
وقال نحن لا نريد الديمقراطيه لقد نجحنا
بدونها
ان في هذه السفينه واحد
الا هو الحاكم ورئيس الدوله هم اللي
ماسكين اما متى ما يصيرون اللهيب
الديمقراطيه والبرلمانات الا هذه هاي ما
تنجح فشله والحين هالغرب في الاقتصاد ولا
نريد انتخابات ولا نريد برلمانات
مدارس استشاريه وهذه ماشيين عليها والحمد
لله امورنا طيبه
[موسيقى]
اقفال حدود ثم فتحها وقتال وقتل ثم هدنا
وصفت بالهشه بين افغانستان وايران مع ضيق
افق الحوار بين الجانبين لا سيما وان
ايران لم تعترف حتى الان بحكومه افغانستان
الجديده التي حلت محل الحكومه المتعاونه
مع الاحتلال الامريكي توتر حدودي بين
ايران وافغانستان بعد اشتباكات داميه جرت
في الايام الماضيه وخلفت قتلى وجرحى
الصدام بين الحرس الثوري الايراني وحركه
طالبان اشعله الخلاف حول حصص البلدين من
مياه نهرها المند في وقت لا تعترف طهران
حتى الان بالحكومه التي شكلت طالبا ربما
حظيت الاشتباكات الاخيره ضوءا اوسع من
سابقاتها لكنها اشتباكات باتت روتينيه على
الحدود وجولتها الاخيره تحمل الرقم 13
يمكن القول بان هذه الاشتباكات يبدو انها
اصبحت جزء من الحياه الاعتياديه على مستوى
الحدود ما بين ايران وما بين افغانستان
وليست المره الاولى وذلك بعناوين متعدده
تحدث هذه الاشتباكات كان هناك تفاهم امني
بين ايران وحركه طالبان ابرمه الجنرال
الراحل قاسم سليماني الذي نعته الحركه
الافغانيه اثر اغتياله ويقضي التفاهم بحسب
موقع ميدل ايست ايل بريطاني بحمايه طالبان
الاقليه الشيعيه في افغانستان مقابل اموال
وتدريبات من الحرس الثوري الايراني
بالاضافه الى منع طهران عوده مقاتلي
ميليشيا فاطميون من سوريا الى افغانستان
لربما تحصل هناك
مناوشات بين الطرفين ان لم يكن هناك اتفاق
بين الطرفين والجلوس الى طاوله مفاوضات
لتحل مشاكل الحدوديه وايضا مشكله المياه
بين الطرفين بكل الاحوال ايران لا تعتبر
طالبان جارا ودودا وقد سبق ان اكد مسؤول
ايراني بارز تعاون طهران مع واشنطن في
الغزو لاسقاط طالبان بحسب التقرير 2001
حمله عسكريه امريكيه على افغانستان بعدها
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر ايران دعمت
احتلال افغانستان واسقاط طالبان وهذا ما
اكده رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
حينها حسين موسويان حيث قال ان تعاون
ايران مع امريكا يهدف الى الاطاحه بحكم
طالبان
المستوطن اليهود اصبحوا في كل عيد ديني
لهم يذهبون الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك بدل
الذهاب الى معابدهم وخليل رفيقه لبهيج
يقول لهم اذا كنتم مغرمين بالاقصى بسيطه
تستطيعون ان تنطقوا بالشهادتين ثم اعتصموا
به ما شئتم في يوم الجمعه ومع اغلاق باب
المغاربه ومنع اقتحامات المستوطنين للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وتتحدى سافر لاهالي مدينه
القدس تجمع عدد من المستوطنين امام ابواب
المسجد الاقصى المبارك مثل باب الاسباط
وباب حطه وسوق القطانين او وسط حراسه
مشدده من شرطه الاحتلال بالتزامن مع عيد
الاسابيع اليهودي
الحكومه الدينيه
للمستوطنين المتطرفه الجديده صار كل اشي
كل مناسبه يتم اغلاق المحلات اغلاق البلده
القديمه منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه تحتفل
بذكرى طلاقتها التاسعه والخمسين وهي ما
تزال تحتل حيزا في وجدان الفلسطينيين وكل
المتضامنين مع الحق الفلسطيني لكنها لم
تؤسس لتصبح متحفا وكلما طال الزمن بها دون
تحرير فلسطين ضعف حضورها وتاثيرها يصادف
الاحد الثامن والعشرين من ايار الذكرى
التاسعه والخمسين لتاسيس منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه عام 964 ممثلا شرعيا ووحيدا
للشعب الفلسطيني في كافه اماكن تواجده
وتاسست المنظمه بعد انعقاد المؤتمر العربي
الفلسطيني الاول في القدس نتيجه لقرار
مؤتمر القمه العربيه الذي انعقد في
القاهره في العام ذاته الخصومه تبدا في
دوله الاحتلال وتصفيه الحساب تكون في
شوارع دبي قتلا بالسكين والشرطه
الاماراتيه تلقي القبضه على عدد من
الاسرائيليين وتقول ان خلفيه الجريمه
ثاريه بين عائلتين لكن المغرد عبد الخالق
عبد الله اطفى عليها بعدا مافيويا تمكنت
القياده العمل لشرطه دبي من القاء القبض
على ثمانيه اشخاص من الجنسيه الاسرائيليه
المتورطين في جريمه الاعتداء والتسبب في
وفاه مواطن من الجنسيه ذاتها وذلك على
خلفيه الصراعات وثار بين عائلتي الطرفين
في المتفرقات فيضانات في الجزائر سببها
هطول امطار غير عاديه يقولون ان المطر خير
لكن الخير فاض وفاض كثيرا حتى جرف معه
الجثمين من قبورها
تنقيب الحكومه المصريه عن ضرائب جديده
تفريضها مستمره والنائب احمد الفرغلي الذي
يطالب برحيل الحكومه لان المشكله فيها في
مصر على قوله يقترح عليها ساخرا فرضا
ضريبه جديده على الصلوات الخمس مع حسومات
في شهر رمضان
قانون من الحكومه بفرض رسوم على الصلوات
يعني اللي عايز يقرب من ربنا يدفع الناس
خلاص ما عادش مستنيه غير كده رائد الفضاء
الاماراتي سلطان يادي يفتقد اثناء الرحله
في عمق الفضاء طبخه والدته
فهل تعدل وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه اسمها من
ناسا الى وناسه الفضاء ممتع يعني ممكن
يسوي كل الحركات اللي في بالنا
يعني ولكن
سهله يشتاق للاكل المطبوخ بالنسبه
الله يحفظها
على الارض
مشروع العفه في الجزائر برنامج سنوي تشرف
عليه جمعيه العلماء المسلمين الجزائريين
حيث يعملوا على دعوه الطالبات الجامعيات
غير المحجبات الى وضع الحجاب والفخر به
الحمد لله استجبنا طواعيه لهذا المشروع
الذي عمره الان سبع سنوات في طبعته
السابعه ككل سنه لا لشيء الا لنقول لهذه
الفتاه ان لك دينا ان لك قبله ان لك
انتسابا لهذه الامه العظيمه امه سيدنا
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في المقابل
المغنيه المصريه التي غالبا ما يسبقها
لسانها تروج لخلع الثياب في الحفلات فتقول
اثناء غنائها في حفلتها بجده لو كنت اعلم
ان الحر شديد لاتيت اليكم بالمايوه
فصفق زوجها والحاضرون شيرين عبد الوهاب
بتصريح المفاجئ خلال حفلها في جده كنت جيت
بالماي وه ومدير اعمالها يتخلى عنها
ويعتذر هو تصريح الفنانه المصريه خلال
حفلها في جده اذ قالت حر قوي مش كنت قولوا
لي كنت جيت بالمايوه تقولوا لي كنت جيت
القيادي في حزب القوات اللبنانيه ابراهيم
الصقر يعلن مدينه زحله الملقبه بمدينه
الكنائس وعاصمه الكثلكه في الشرق يعلنها
مدينه للعرق والخمور ويدعو الى مقاطعه فرن
لانه لا يبيع الخمور في زحل المختلطه بين
اتباع مختلف المذاهب والديانات في مطعم
فرن وملحمه وفرن
فتح بزحله
صارت الزحاني كلها تشتري من عنده شويه
فجات انه ما بيبيع بيره ما ببيع وسكي ما
ببيع ما بيبيع مشروبات روحيه يا اخي ما
تفتح عندي ما انت جاي على زحله اسمها
مدينه الخمر وقطعوه في ملاحم كثير بزحله
للزحان يروحوا يشتروا من عندها لشو عم
تروح توقفوا بالصف تشتروا من عنده وهو عم
يضرب لك سقافتك اذا كنت ترفض ترويج او
تعاطي الخمور عليك ان تخرج من زحله اما
اذا كنت تؤيد الاح امام امام الناس الذي
اقرته بلديه صيدا المدينه ذات الاغلبيه
المسلمه فعليك ايضا ان تغادرها الى قندهار
بافغانستان يقول المحروس لان هذا ليس من
ثقافته فلماذا لا ينقل نفوسه هو الى شواطئ
العراه في اليونان يسال بهيج طلع باله حدا
يعمل قانون على ذوقه انه والله يا خيي
ممنوع تلبسي ميه يا اخي ما تطلعش فيها اذا
هالقد انت المليون مزعجك طلعوا ببيتك او
او نقول نفوسك على كندهار هونيك في بلاد
اسلاميه
مضطرفه متعصبه طلعوا هي انت فيك تعيش
بلبنان هيك ممنوع الاحتشام ليس ماده
خلافيه بين ثقافه المسلمين وثقافه
المسيحيين
وغيرهما من الثقافات التي تامر بالستر
انما الخلاف حول الاحتشام هو بين الثقافات
الدينيه على اختلافها وثقافه اللادينيه
الغربيه التي منعت رجال الدين المسيحيين
من قول كلمتهم في داخل الغرب وشجعت على
هجران الكنائس ما هي ضوابط ملابس المراه
في المسيحيه
الفكره
يعني الانجيل ذكرها بطريقه مباشره هي مبدا
الحشمه
والحشمه معناها او هدفها هو
صون المراه من المتطفلين
او المسيئين قررت السلطات الهولنديه منع
تدخين القنه بالهندي الحشيش المخدر في
الحي الاحمر بامستردام الذي يعتبر مرتعا
لسياحه الجنس والمخدرات وسط معارضه اقليه
مستفيده من تجاره المخدرات
وتعاطيها وهنا يرد السؤال الى دعاه الحريه
المفتوحه في الغرب
ومقلديهم في الشرق بلا زغره اليس للاكثريه
ان تمنع الاقليه عما تراه الاكثريه ضررا
للمجتمع
المجتمعات المحافظه هذا ما تفعله بالتحديد
وتحد من المسكرات ايضا لان ضحاياها اكثر
من ضحايا المخدرات رب بات حظر تدخين
الحشيش او القنب الهندي في امستردام ساريا
منذ يوم الخميس الخامس والعشرين من شهر
مايو الجري وتحديدا في شوارع الحي الاحمر
في وسط العاصمه الهولنديه المعروف ببيوت
الدعاره الكثيره في شوارعه والذي يعاني
معدلات جريمه مرتفعه في لبنان يتوالى
اعتزال السياسيين السياسه بشكل صوري فبعد
تعليق الرئيس سعد الحريري عمله السياسيه
الى اجل غير مسمى دون ان يغيب تاثيره عن
بيروت وليد جمبلاط يخلع عباءه الزعامه
الدرزيه المباشره ويلبسها لابنه تيمور
فيستقيل من رئاسه الحزب التقدمي الاشتراكي
افساحا في المجال لنجله بما يشبه الخروج
من صالون السياسه الى غرفه معيشتها
ولجمبلاط يفتتح بهذه الخطوه مرحله جديده
من تاريخ الحزب انسحب الى مقاعد الترقب
واتقاء رياح المتغيرات
موجودا سيبقى للنصح والتوجيه وان كان جواب
المرحله اسالوا تيمور وفق حسابات رئيس حزب
التوحيد العربي وئام وهاب فانه يتبقى
ثلاثه سياسيين لبنانيين غيابهم مطلوب
للمجتمع الدولي الذي كلف فرنسا اداره
انهيار لبنان بواقعه الحالي اما الثلاثه
الاخرون قيد الاختفاء بحسب وهاب فهم نبيه
بري وسمير جعجع وجبران باسيل الذي زار هوب
على راسه وفد ربما للوداع اذا اخذنا كلامه
على محمل الجد يعني الفرنسي اخذ قرار في
خمس يخلص منهم
واخرته راح اقول لك سعد الحريري واحد نبي
بري اثنين عرفت كيف جبران باشيل ثلاثه
ولجملات اربعه سمير شجع خمسه او خمسه رح
يخلصوا منهم
ختاما واقتباسا من قصه حقيقيه حدثت في
كندا محطه محروقات كانت تعاني من الركود
فوظف صاحبها عاملا جديدا ليكتشف بعد عده
اشهر نموا كبيرا في المبيعات بسبب هذا
العامل الذي باتت الزبائن تعرفه وتناديه
باسمه ساله صاحب المحطه كيف استحوذت على
اعجاب الزبائن فاعترف له بالسر عندما ياتي
الزبون لاول مره يساله عن اسمه فيدونه
بقلم صغير على غطاء خزان الوقود من الداخل
ليستطيع في المره التاليه التعرف عليه عند
فتح الغطاء دون سؤال فيقترب من السائق
ويناديه باسمه مطمئنا عن احواله وهكذا صار
العامل صديقا محبوبا لنصف سائقي المدينه
مكافاه له قرر صاحب المحطه منحه نسبه
قليله من الارباح
الخلاصه تميز في عملك مهما كان عملك فبائع
قهوه شغوف فاعل افضل من امبراطور فاشل الى
اللقاء
لهدف وسعيلك عمره ما يوم وقف في حياتي ما
تعودت صدف ما يخيب صرار نابع من شغف
[موسيقى]